yo no kimochi yo cuckoo hotel ballerina
Bernardo Scaparrotti Tecna yoga logic
name
private companies education or Oh pal a
beauty recrea go as an assault charge
attack every shot Yogi Berra husband
Roger cly of Qi solder
survivor Bishop e5 survivor Kappa me
Joker p.m. cookie CEO / depending on the
parapets gender or put some Gucci
Cartier
mostly guess is one side love cabbage a
sorta cure Chico Hopkin ie here open a
person killer case a shoddy cornica
I believe that the sharrows cafe is in
Agra the monument for love and
resilience first I felt betrayed but
what happened to these girls but
actually when you speak to these girls
you realize that ye are complete human
beings with feelings and emotions and I
feel this really really touching